Amy Goodman what is the title the
exception to the rulers mean it really
should be the motto of all journalism
all media today and that is the
exception to the rulers there is a
reason why our profession journalism is
the only one protected by enshrined in
the Constitution because we are supposed
to be the check and balance on
government the exception to the rulers
for somebody it's never heard of you
have never seen you where do you do your
work well I'm the host of democracy now
that comes out of Pacifica Network
Pacifica was founded fifty-five years
ago by a man named Lew hill he was a
conscientious objector refused to fight
in World War two when he came out of the
detention camps he says there has T said
there has to be a media outlet run not
by corporations that profit from war but
by journalists and artists and so
Pacifica Radio went on the air April 15
1949 it was three o'clock in the
afternoon Lew Hill welcomed people to
the airwaves of the first Pacifica
station KPFA
he had to give out FM radios because FM
was in its infancy and then immediately
as they turned it on he was asking for
money because Pacifica pioneered the
idea of listener sponsored radio it's
been adopted by NPR and PBS the idea of
not turning to corporations but turning
to listeners for support the idea of not
being run by corporations that as george
gerbner professor of journalism at the
Annenberg School at University of
Pennsylvania and founder of the cultural
environment movement says not run by
corporations that have nothing to tell
and everything to sell that are raising
our children today Pacifica Network grew
to five stations in the 1950s Paul
Robeson the great actor intellectuals
singer activist when he was white listed
from almost everywhere in this country
except a few black churches knew he
could be heard on KPFA James Baldwin
debating Malcolm X on the effectiveness
of nonviolent civil disobedience the
luncheon the nonviolent civil
disobedience the
lunch counter sit-ins of the South knew
he would be broadcast on WBAI and then
when our Houston station KPFT
went on air in 1970 it's the only radio
station in the country whose transmitter
was blown up in fact it was blown up
twice by the Ku Klux Klan and when the
exalted Cyclops our Grand Dragon I get
their titles confused talked about it he
said it was his proudest act I think
because he understood how dangerous
Pacifica is dangerous because it allows
people to speak for themselves and when
you hear someone speaking from their own
experience that breaks down bigotry and
stereotypes that lead to these hate
groups so for many years now the
Pacifica family of five stations WBAI in
New York WPF W in Washington with KPFT
in Houston KPFA in Berkeley and KPFK in
Los Angeles and then all the community
radio station affiliates we have
provided a sanctuary for dissent and I
think that's so important I think
dissent makes this country healthy
that's where I come from democracy now
was founded in 1996 as the only daily
election show in public broadcasting I
host that show a daily uninvaded
international independent grassroots
Newshour several years ago we were on
several dozen community radio stations
and now we are broadcasting on over 220
pacifica radio stations and affiliates
increasingly NPR stations public access
TV stations around the country now we're
on PBS and we broadcast on DISH Network
free speech TV which is Channel nine
four one five the oldest nonprofit TV
station in the country what time of day
is your radio show we actually broadcast
at 8:00 a.m. Eastern Standard Time
but stations around the country run it
when they want to how long is it
it's an hour you have guests and do you
take calls we don't take calls because
it is run at different times through the
day around the country we also broadcast
on radio stations across Canada
across Australia and in Europe and at
democracynow.org our website we video an
audio stream and we get millions of hits
a month sometimes a week for our
broadcasts we the show is all guests it
is debate dialogue about the most
important issues of the day let me just
start by asking you the book is
published by Hyperion my last
recollection is that's owned by Disney
right it surprise you that a Disney
company would publish your book it did
one of the higher-ups in the company
knew my work from East Timor in fact his
mother had been to East Timor and also
there the publisher of / Medea and not
the tour who was one of the leading
Indonesian dissident writers and because
I had done so much work around Indonesia
and Timor he was familiar with it I've
read your book and I'd have to say at
the end of it I gather that you're
fairly angry about a lot of things is
that fair I think the media has reached
an all-time low in this country and that
is a terrible violation of what our
profession is supposed to do we are
supposed to hold those in power
accountable we're not supposed to cozy
up to those in power not supposed to get
the perks of the powerful we are
supposed to be there to if not keep the
politicians honest show what's going on
and it is very serious now because we're
talking about war time we're talking
about for example now the invasion of
Iraq and the occupation and when the
media acts as a conveyor belt for the
lies of the administration we not only
are violating our responsibility but
those lies take lives just look at the
number of servicemen and women who have
died in Iraq over 700 not to mention the
number of Iraqi civilians who have died
over 10,000 now that was the population
that the Bush administration supposedly
said
we were going in to liberate and to save
and now more than 10,000 dead you were
at an award ceremony for the Overseas
Press Group and Tom Brokaw was emceeing
the night and you were getting an award
what's the story
well that was April 22nd 1999 it was in
the midst of the bombing of Yugoslavia
and I had recently returned from Nigeria
Africa's most populous country with my
colleague Democracy Now producer and
correspondent Jeremy Scahill
we had gone to investigate the Chevron
Corporation and what it was doing in the
Niger Delta we had discovered the story
in May of 1998 in a place called Elijah
land in the Niger Delta that the Chevron
Corporation was working there drilling
for oil and the people were disgusted
with yet another oil spill that hadn't
been cleaned up and they went to a
Chevron Oil barge and they protested and
demanded to speak to the higher-ups to
negotiate with them for cleanup for more
jobs they were on the barge for several
days they thought that the Chevron
executives were going to be flown in but
instead in came on Chevron helicopters
the Nigerian military and the notorious
mobile police known as the killin go
that's the kill and go and when they
came from the helicopters on to the
barge they opened fire they killed two
of the Nigerian villagers they
critically wounded a third had the
others rounded up put in the notorious
Nigerian jail somewhere tortured we
talked to these people we learned their
story and then we went to Lagos and we
talked to the Chevron executive and
asked what had happened and he said yes
we flew them in we flew in the Nigerian
military and he admitted it all we came
back to the United States we questioned
chevron corporation headquartered in
California largest corporation oil
corporation headquartered in California
and they said we had talked to their
officials we had the story and so we did
the documentary drilling and killing
Chevron and Nigeria's oil
tater ship and it won a number of awards
one of them was a citation from the
overseas press club that night we went
to the dinner we actually weren't going
to go because it was in the midst of the
bombing of Yugoslavia and we couldn't
afford the hundred $25 a plate even the
winners would have had to pay it so but
then we thought well you know we'll
stand at the back we'll record the
ceremony and with having Tom Brokaw
reading the title maybe we could record
him saying it inserted into the
documentary and people would find it
more believable write the title drilling
and killing Chevron Nigeria's oil
dictatorship so we're at the back and an
official from the club got off to
welcome everyone they're about to have
dinner and then have the award ceremony
and he said I want to congratulate you
all for being here I know these are very
tough times for reporters overseas very
dangerous but there is a ray of hope and
it's Indonesia and how they're treating
journalists what this was 1999 in the
lead-up to the elections and Timor the
Indonesian military and it's militias
were rampaging through Timor even the
New York Times had written about it that
week journalists were being beaten up
journalists continued to be banned what
is he talking about and so when they sat
down to dinner and well we had no dinner
we were sitting standing in the back I
walked over and I said where did you get
that information that the Indonesian is
the Indonesian government is treating
journalists better and he said well I
wrote to the Foreign Ministry and they
said that a reporter writing to the
Foreign Ministry and just accepting them
at word and accepting their word I said
well we have information otherwise and
he said well why don't you fax it to me
and I'll consider it because I had asked
him to go up in the dais and correct
what he had said anyway went back to the
back and there was Richard Holbrooke he
was about to deliver a major address for
the dinner we went to ask him some
questions he was one of the major
figures in the bombing of Yugoslavia
acting as the US envoy in the Balkans
he just brushed us off that's every
politicians right but what disturbed us
is that one of the heads of the Overseas
Press Club came over and said what do
you think you're doing I said asking
Richard Holbrooke a question should no
no we made an agreement with him he
wouldn't have come here tonight if we
agreed that journalists wouldn't ask him
questions and I said well first of all
he shouldn't come here and second of all
I make no such agreement and the reason
I felt he shouldn't be there is we have
to challenge this cozy relationship of
journalists and politicians why are they
honoring a politician when that night
they're honoring the highest values and
the good works of journalists and it's
something that happens all over
Washington but anyway they continued
with their dinner and then the awards
ceremony began not before Holbrooke
delivered a major address congratulating
the network's naming them individually
saying how well they were doing with the
coverage of the bombing of Yugoslavia I
don't consider that a badge of honor but
after he finished my colleague Jeremy
Scahill went up as people were
applauding and said I have a question
for you and it was about Appendix B of
the Rambla Accord which called for a
total occupation of Yugoslavia that
Milosevic would have to accept and
whatever you think of Milosevic it was
probable that the head of a sovereign
nation would not accept a total
occupation and later turned out to be
the case that the threshold was
deliberately set too high it was
Holbrook who delivered the ultimatum to
Milosevic the Rambla Accord and so he
said he asked that question about
appendix B and wasn't the threshold set
too high deliberately high anyway he
tried to ask it and he said he asked for
support from his colleagues in the press
I think it was Lesley Stahl and Tom
Brokaw at the table and Tom Brokaw told
him to be quiet and sit down and had
security take Jeremy out and if they
were pulling him out they had to pass me
at the back in a sudden release that
Manny's about to win an award and
security was a little confused but they
released him and the ceremony began and
they began by introducing Tom Brokaw
another official of the Overseas Press
Club saying you get to know the measure
of men when you're on a plane with him
for 17 hours he said in 1975 he was on
Kissinger's plane with Tom Brokaw and he
sat with him for many many hours they
would sit then have canapes at the front
with Henry Kissinger and then sit back
down again I thought this was a
caricature of what journalists shouldn't
be doing and then the Tom Brokaw got up
and the ceremony began he started to
giving out the awards and saying the
titles of people's work and broadcast
prynt and he came to our category and he
said and then for drilling and killing
any goodman in jeremy scahill and i went
up on the stage and said mr. Brokaw
thank you but no thank you and I said
something like in the name of that
documentary is drilling and killing
Chevron and Nigeria's oil dictatorship
but we couldn't accept for two reasons
one because they'd made an agreement
with a politician not to ask them
questions that we're here not to applaud
politicians but to challenge them and
number two because of the organization
commending Indonesia which was
responsible for the beading and banning
and killing of journalists so I said
thank you but no thank you and I got off
the stage and Tom Brokaw said it's a
great country it's a great first
amendment and he said something like
Pacifica willing will carry on he got a
little embarrassed I think when he you
know I said I'm Amy Goodman that was
Jeremy Scahill who you had taken out
because of a few weeks before a little
while before he had gone to the Today
Show which he had once anchored and I
think it was Katie Couric at the time
said to him how does it feel to come
back to your old haunt he was on a book
tour with his latest book and he said
something like at the time well you know
walking down the street at 3 o'clock in
the morning seeing the homeless people I
envy them because they got more sleep
than I did and I got a titter in the
gossip press and I think now he was
thinking oh god it's gonna happen again
because he tried to have taken out one
of the award winners and so he somehow
said through the evening well Richard
Holbrooke has agreed to talk to you
afterwards and started making jokes
about Pacifica throughout at the end of
the ceremony was interesting one of the
editors at Businessweek came over to
shake my hand and said we had talked on
the phone before and I thought about it
and it was true a few months before
Businessweek had done an amazing story
it was called what mobile knew and it
was about the Indonesia how mobile the
allegations that they had provided the
excavating equipment to the Indonesian
government that they had used to put mat
bodies in
of the mobile workers and others in this
amazing photograph of a man holding a
skull and Businessweek had done an
incredible piece and we call them at the
time so we'd like to have on your
reporter and in the end they said no not
because they didn't want to come on but
the lawyers felt it was best so they'd
publish it but they wouldn't talk about
it
and this was the editor involved and so
it was nice to meet him and I said but
what are you doing here so what we just
got that award the Merrill Lynch Award
for good report and so it works it was
Pepsi Cola Coca Cola award for good
reporting and Merrill Lynch it's all
under the rubric of overseas Press Club
but their corporate sponsored Awards
most of them Susa we just won that award
I said but he's Tom Brokaw is reading
all the titles yeah he didn't say
Chevron and ours Chevron and Nigeria's
all dictatorship but he didn't say what
mobile knew for yours as well whatever
he said it was for Indonesian reporting
and so the dinner ended we Richard
Holbrooke did not agree to allow us to
really interview him lesley stahl was
standing next to him and said Dec I'll
take you home
as we were questioning him trying to
question him went back to Brokaw he said
he had something else to do I used the
opportunity I saw Frank Sesno from CNN
and I asked him what he thought of the
policy of CNN and the other networks
putting military officials on the
payroll but not putting peace activists
on the payroll to have a real dialogue
and he said they had discussed that
issue but they had decided against it
because military generals were analysts
and peace activists were advocates
analyst advocates I think I need an
analyst to figure out that one but I
asked him why not someone like Noam
Chomsky very well-known figure you have
had on here and he said I don't know him
personally and I looked at the whole
room hundreds of journalists sitting
with the politicians and I thought well
this is how the system works you get to
know them personally at these black-tie
events and that's who you invite in but
that doesn't represent most of America
I'm not talking about a fringe minority
I'm not talking about a silent majority
I'm talking about the silence
majority silenced by the corporate media
page 164 you're on the Charlie Rose show
and this is what Charlie Rose said and
you can explain how it fits in the
argument I have with respect is Peter
Jennings Tom Brokaw and Dan Rather a
whole range of people are journalists
who are paid have paid their dues and
they are very competent journalists who
are reporting for magazines and those
broadcasts what what was going on
between you and Charlie Rose well I was
a little surprised myself that morning
The Washington Post had done a profile
it was called peace correspondent and
within an hour two if it coming out I
got a call from the Charlie Rose show
and they asked if I wanted to be on that
evening so I raced over because they
tape in advance and and we did the
taping of the program and Charlie Rose
started the segment by saying can you
tell me where you broadcast and I said
well on over 220 stations and PR
Pacifica the public access TV and now
PBS and just went through the whole
thing it sounded to me a little like an
ad on my part and I thought yeah it's
not usually how the Charlie Rose show
goes but he had asked so I just said
that's all to say that we need
independent media in a time of war and
he seemed to take great offense at that
and say what are you suggesting by that
well just that we need independent media
in a time of war and he asked about he
said that you know he worked at CBS as
well and he said what are you suggesting
these are my friends he said you're
talking about Tom Brokaw and Peter
Jennings he made it very personal and
Dan Rather and I said I was just talking
about the whole system and the way it
works and I said you don't have to just
believe me take the words of Dan Rather
when he was on BBC on Newsnight he said
that I think he used the term he would
be necklace.if he asked tough questions
let me read it this is a quote from the
BBC dan Rather there was a time in South
Africa the
would put flaming tires around people's
necks if they descended he said and in
some ways the fear is that you will be
necklace here you will have a flaming
tire of lack of patriotism put around
your neck now it is that fear that keeps
journalists from asking the toughest of
the tough questions and to continue to
bore in on the tough question so often
and again I am humbled to say I not
accept myself from this criticism right
and that was the quote and I took and I
paraphrased it and I said exactly that
that he felt he would be necklace if he
were to ask the hard questions and
Charlie Rose just couldn't believe it he
said he's my friend he wouldn't say
something along those lines like that I
can't believe he would say something
like that and I said I'm just quoting
him and but it was a very interesting
discussion we did talk about independent
media in a time of war I think they were
overwhelmed with responses on their
website you could read them afterwards
he ran it a few days later and I think
the reason was it was his viewers that
were overwhelmingly responding to him
not people that particularly knew me or
watched her listen to Democracy Now that
they were surprised a lot of them called
for him to apologize they were surprised
at how he treated me because he usually
doesn't engage people like that I think
it's probably because he usually has
people on he agrees with and they were
whether they agreed with me or not
they were surprised at the interaction a
lot of them also to my surprise sent him
the quote from BBC of what Dan Rather
said later on page 207 so the mainstream
media dutifully reported that there was
no objection to war and we're not just
talking Fox News on April the 8th 2001
on NPR's Morning Edition Cokie Roberts
was asked if there were any dissenters
in Congress quote none that matter
unquote she replied well that's a very
big problem it does matter when dissent
is considered irrelevant and we went on
to talk about David patottie who lost
his brother James at the World Trade
Center he picked up on that quote and a
very powerful essay that he wrote
and he said can we expect any of the
networks to ever report on dissent and
he said none that matter and he went on
with a litany of none that matter
dissent does matter it's what makes this
country healthy and the media has a
responsibility to go to where the
silence is to present the views of
people all over this country and not
simply beat the drums for war and that's
precisely what they did in this lead-up
to the invasion you look at the two-week
period before and after General Colin
Powell made his case for war at the UN
Security Council that was February 5th
2003 fairness and accuracy in reporting
fair did a study they looked at the four
major nightly newscasts CBS NBC ABC and
PBS news hour with Jim Lehrer that
two-week period the pivotal time it was
just a month before the u.s. invaded
Iraq and there were 393 interviews done
around war on these four major nightly
newscasts three only three of almost 400
were with anti-war representatives this
at a time when most people in this
country were against the invasion and
for more time for inspections and
diplomacy that is not an independent
media that is not a media that is giving
voice to this country that is a media
that is hell-bent on war and it is
violating or sacred responsibilities to
be fair who says media has to be fair I
think it does I think it's why we our
profession is protected by the
Constitution it is essential that the
media provide a forum for all views now
it's not just us at Pacifica Radio and
NPR and PBS that are using the public
airwaves they are - and that is part of
our mandate they don't own the airwaves
that is a national treasure our airwaves
they are leasing them and there are
responsibilities
that come with that leasing from these
are the payments these are the public
airwaves and well we have a whole
chapter an exception to the rulers on on
the direction broadcasting has gone on
the FCC under Michael Powell although it
goes back to the Clinton administration
as well we're supposed to hold all those
in power accountable it's not the Bush
administration alone or the Clinton
administration alone but all of them
the FCC run by that chair is Michael
Powell son of : Powell he leads the war
in Iraq his son leads the war on
diversity of voices at home going in a
very corporate direction thinks he can
get away with it with stealth moves
changing the rules tries to hold only
one public hearing when they're gonna
change the rules that will lead to the
largest media consolidation in this
country's history they try to hold one
public hearing and the dead of winter in
Richmond Virginia it's in the middle of
a snowstorm and this is going to be how
people find out what happens but thanks
to independent media specifically
pacifica radio broadcasting informal
hearings that the dissident
commissioners Michael Copps and Jonathan
Adelstein held all over the country
together with the unions and media
activist groups to get people's views
and thousands of people would turn out
on these arcane rule changes that would
lead to for example allowing Fox and
Viacom which now on CBS to penetrate
more into reaching more of the American
public now there's been a cap at 35
percent the network's can't reach beyond
35 and they wanted to go to 45 percent
because they already own it and if they
stayed at 35 percent they'd have to sell
off some of the stations and they didn't
want to but because of these hearings it
was remarkable people came out of
everywhere Congress and the FCC got more
than 2 million responses and when people
heard about this it wasn't a progressive
or a conservative thing across the
political spectrum people revolted they
said no it is not healthy for a medium
to own the newspaper the television the
radio in one town so everyone from Trent
Lott to Barbara Boxer is raking Michael
Powell over the coals at a Senate
hearing saying what's going on here
think he was completely stunned by the
level of response
it wasn't thanks to the corporate media
they hardly did a story in a year ABC
NBC and CBS on this instead behind the
scenes they are filing joint briefs in
support of the deregulation because they
will benefit you thought they were
competitors well they're there behind
the scenes working together and we
demand better than that
for all of us where did you grow up I
was born here in Washington DC my dad
worked at the National Institutes of
Health and then I moved then my family
moved to New York when I was a baby and
and I grew up in Long Island New York
where did you go to high school Bay
Shore High School the public high school
in our Community College
I went to Harvard Radcliffe College
what'd you study anthropology can you
remember when you first cared about a
political issue hmm well I think I
always felt strongly about holding those
in power accountable at the time it was
my parents but then my parents were my
role model in that my father led the
task force in our community in Bay Shore
to integrate the schools and it got very
rowdy at times I think I was in fifth
grade at the time but I would go with
him at night to the school cafeterias a
thousand people would turn out they he
dealt with death threats and certainly
screaming assemblies of people - the
idea was to have schools buy grades not
buy neighborhoods and that way we would
all be integrated and he just provided
the steady guiding hand for our whole
community and it led to together with
the other task force members the
integration of our schools and I just
watched that
sense of judicious nnessee had of
hearing out what everyone had to say and
moving forward and I really respected
that and my mom was a professor of
women's studies history and literature
in community colleges and then became a
social worker and was a great model for
me where did they get their activism I
think from their parents my grandfather
and my mother's side was an Orthodox
rabbi deeply committed to educating to
education he was the principal of a
local yeshiva school and instilled and
my mother my grandmother as well that
reverence for education my grandmother
is still alive we're now celebrating her
107th birthday and so she's also taught
us endurance and optimism and just
keeping on was there anybody in your
family who was a member of a political
party wasn't an active political
activist but all had come from Russia
and fled persecution my grandparents on
my father's side as well and we just
grew up with that just deeply instilled
with a sense of social justice and many
of my family died in the Holocaust and
feeling well it's a slogan we have heard
many times but I apply it to everyone
and that is never again what did you do
when I graduated from Radcliffe came
back home to New York and I was turning
my college thesis into a series of
articles for the multinational monitor
here in Washington what was the thesis
the thesis was on a contraceptive drug
called depo-provera it was a medical
anthropology thesis and it looked at how
women around the world had been injected
with a strug you injected into the arm
once every three months in 86 countries
it had been shipped to by then the OP
Jon company and in Kalamazoo Michigan
which has been absorbed by other
pharmaceutical companies since but it
had never been
proved by the FDA it cause cancer and
beagles and monkeys I couldn't afford
for the thesis to go traveling around
the world to the places where women had
been injected and then never followed up
on but it could go down to Atlanta
Georgia to the Grady Hospital which was
one of the largest charity hospitals in
the country and their 10,000 black women
have been injected with the quote the
shot not knowing it had not been
approved by the FDA many had been sick
it led to the establishment of the black
woman's health project led by Billy
Avery one of the leading women rights
activists in this country and I thought
you know here people do so much work on
theses so much research and we present
it to but a few men in a small room and
that's going to be it in fact I remember
the day going in to defend my thesis and
the Anthropology professors were sitting
back and one of them smoking his pipe
said miss Goodman do you know what it
means to be an anthropologist I said I
think so
and he said because you cannot observe
your own society I was looking at
science on society how science fits in
this is not anthropology so I said well
dr. so-and-so I am looking at the
scientific and medical establishment in
this country which is mainly white male
and corporate I do not consider myself a
part of that establishment and so I
think I can take a very valid
anthropological look at them carry on
and I did and we turned this series I
did it with my colleague and college
christina van Henneberg who's a
professor now in california and we
turned this series into an issue of the
multinational monitor called the case
against depo-provera and as i was
writing those articles at home i tuned
in to the radio and I heard this
remarkable place there was WBAI which
was it just all I heard was the voices
tentacles not trying to sell me anything
describing all of the glory and horror
that is New York City and all its myriad
of accents all the different experiences
of people I thought what is this place
and I had gone off to take some graduate
classes at our local college Hunter I
was actually interested in biochemistry
and nutrition so I was taking
biochemistry classes and they were
teaching a radio documentary course and
I went over and the professor was a
producer WBAI that remarkable place that
I listen to and afterwards I said could
I help in any way and he said I could
apprentice with him he was starting a
new show called
investigations he was from Australia so
we have that kind of speech impediment
and uh we walked over to Vai that night
and I never left
what year was that that was 1985 and how
long did it take Pacifica to get other
radio stations and expand
well Pacifica at that point as of 1977
with WPF W in Washington that was our
five stations and it hasn't and those
are the five stations wholly owned by
Pacifica Radio unlike NPR which doesn't
own stations but they take NPR
programming Pacifica actually the
Pacifica foundation based in Berkeley
California owns five stations but we
provide programming to any station in
the country Democracy Now which we began
in 1996 is now airing on well beyond the
Pacifica stations to NPR and TV stations
an hour a day Democracy Now yes and can
you find it on the web if people want to
listen democracynow.org and there we
video stream we audio stream we have the
transcripts of all the programs because
we close caption which means 28 million
Americans can now have access to us the
Deaf and the hard of hearing which is
very exciting to have access to Pacifica
programming but then we take the closed
captioning transcripts working with the
National captioning Institute and and
just clean them up because they're they
I mean it's amazing these transcribers
how fast they go how incredible they are
but then we put them on the website and
and anyone can access this a lot of
professors and teachers or working with
transcripts on our whole website using
them as part of their curriculum and
it's very exciting democracynow.org when
you confront people like on the stage at
the Overseas Press Club or on Capitol
Hill which we're gonna show you on it's
just a moment does it make you nervous
sir I mean how do you get ready to
confront a big name whether it be a big
media type or the Speaker of the House I
don't in these examples that you give
like the Overseas Press Club I did not
plan to go up and reject the citation
it's what happened at that moment in the
case you're going to describe it it
wasn't planned but it will say that in
doing interviews it takes research and
really doing our homework and we have
amazing team of producers at democracy
now and we work around the clock
culling stories information from a broad
range of newspapers and broadcasts
around the world from people telling us
their stories that never get into the
mainstream media but it just happens now
this event we're going to show is what
year do you remember this was 1995 I
think it was March 3rd 1995 right after
soon after the 50th day of the first
hundred days of the Republican
revolution Congress and I might just put
a you know parochial note in that we had
asked for years to be able to televise
the speaker's news conference every day
and when speaker Gingrich came in they
gave his permission and it was because
of things like this that you're gonna
see that they shut it down
and I want to ask you about that whether
or not politicians are willing to deal
with things like this after we show this
videotape your voice is what people are
hearing many people are talking about
what's going on the house is a war on
women that most of the poor are women
the whole issue about reproductive
rights that keeps getting raised but
this is a question
that legislation a some say you really
fire the opening salvo against women
when you didn't apologize to American
women for Kohler and calling the first
lady of [ __ ] I never say I never said I
never agreed to say anything about that
and I can't imagine you're asking this
question why are you apologizing to mrs.
Clinton she understands exactly where
where I never said I never said the best
my knowledge I never said what you just
said you're okay now I'm calling you a
remarkably foolish person for having
that kind of a conversation here and I
am very sorry you would care to bring
what Connie Chung did back into the
public arena Connie Chung lied to mine
Connie Chung lied to my mother you are
now trying to exploit a lie by a
professional reporter to my mother and
I'm not going to take any more comments
from you I think it is very embarrassing
the you as a reporter we try to take any
use of Connie Chung having lied to my
mother I think you should be ashamed I
think you should be as yes it is because
because I didn't I say one more time
you're trying to use my mother and what
I think is a very despicable way and I
am very I think it is very sad and I
have advised my mother talked to no
reporters because of precisely this kind
of exploitation by people like you the
next question yes sir
what do you remember besides what you
just saw well as you said speakers
conference was newly being broadcast Tom
Foley the speaker before didn't allow
that and I felt that Newt Gingrich was
using it as a way simply using the
reporters as props as a way to speak get
his message out his daily message to the
American people and journalists
shouldn't be used like that I mean
people would ask questions
some of them tough it didn't matter
though he would just get out his daily
message didn't able to answer the
questions and at the 50th day into the
first hundred days which were a very
important marker for him he assessed all
the different institutions and he said
he felt speaker's conference was going
very well and there's some reporters
there who
as my grandma would say Keld you know
who just were so proud when he said that
and that's saying that about all our
reporters but that is not a badge of
honor that he was using it almost as if
he was the conductor of an orchestra and
reporters were supposed to be there with
the dissonant notes with the questions
with the very serious grilling and after
that period I was very disturbed at that
this was my last day in Washington at
that time we were doing a show called
the hundred days of Congress and I had
actually just raced over for the last
news conference I didn't particularly
plan on asking a question but it just
came to me as he was talking and it had
been something that was on my mind this
had actually happened a few months
before where the whole story of Connie
Chung questioning his mother about
talking to her and his mother turning to
her and saying this is what my son
called the first lady and I thought you
know this is the Speaker of the House
his words matter and as I covered
Congress
I saw a day after day what was going on
they weren't talking about issues like
abortion in fact it wasn't even in the
contract on some say contract of America
contract on America it wasn't in there
but in fact daily and the different
subcommittees and committees these are
they were talking about women's
reproductive rights they were gradually
eating away it wasn't getting the
coverage though and I wanted to ask the
speaker about this and about his comment
because I thought the language laid the
groundwork for the legislation this also
had recently followed what Dick Armey
had said you know number two men in the
house when he was talking to radio
reporters and he said Barney [ __ ] I mean
Barney Frank and the way he attacked the
reporters immediately excuse me they
didn't say it he said it and he the way
he defended himself was by saying he
hadn't had his morning coffee yet now I
believe that I believe he was used to
saying that in private and it just sort
of slipped out but at that time there
was a series of brutal murders of gay
men in Texas where he comes from
he was opposing hate crimes legislation
in Congress their words matter and it
was sending a message
American people when Newt Gingrich said
I've already apologized I already
discussed this with Hillary Clinton I
had no idea if he had I sort of doubted
it but I couldn't say that wasn't true
but it goes beyond the individual
conversation at that point he had said
it about the first lady and and he had
sent a message to all women and he's
never denied it and I felt that it
needed a response shortly after that
they shut cameras down forever
we've never been back in we better off
well
sorry Brian but I don't think it was my
fault no I'm not blaming now there are
others it did help fronted the speaker I
just wanted are we better off you know
we are not how do we work this out
because I think it's very important to
for there to be transparency I had come
back to Washington to cover one of the
hearings on I think it was approving a
new director of Central Intelligence
something and I opened the Washington
Post and I saw that Newt Gingrich was
shutting it down it was at the end of
April and he used as an excuse a
reference that I think clearly referred
to that that he was going to shut it
down and I'll tell you what I thought it
was at the time I thought it even before
let's not forget what happened in April
of 1995 April 19th I think it was the
blowing up of the Alfred Murrah Building
in Oklahoma City Timothy McVeigh and the
more Newt Gingrich spoke spewing this
anti-government rhetoric really
hate-filled the more unpopular he became
and I think he needed an excuse to shut
this down sounding a little too familiar
with the kind of stuff we were hearing
coming out of the ranks of those people
that Timothy McVeigh represented or he
himself I really felt that at the time
and I thought how is he going to deal
with this the more he speaks the more
people dislike him and I think that's
why he shut it down where do you operate
your program
Democracy Now broadcasts out of downtown
community television nonprofit Community
Media Center in Chinatown it's in a
hundred-year-old decommissioned
firehouse Engine Company 31 and we
broadcast now out of the the Bay's of
the first floor where the trucks used to
come in and out we used to be in the
garret actually it's September 11th 2001
we're just blocks from ground zero we
were broadcasting the show when the
planes hit is there any way to
characterize how much it cost to do
democracy now for a year I don't know
the exact budget I'll just say it is a
fraction of the corporate networks to
say the least
but it is a team of absolutely
remarkable producers who are just
completely committed it's both
television and radio we're the only ones
doing that daily and the first daily
national public broadcast on radio and
television at the same time and it's
really opened up a new world going to
television first of all most people are
people get most of the news from
television so it's very important images
really matter and to be able to
broadcast the images for example of war
and we talked about this in the book to
counter the sanitized media is very very
important people listen to radio won't
even know that the images are going by
but people who watch television see the
film and photos of the independent
journalists who are out there
videographers and photographers and also
corporate those who work for the network
so don't get some of this stuff on their
stations it's very important I'm not for
reality television except when it comes
to war then I am for showing exactly
what's happening when it comes to money
on this book are you taking the money
yourself
no the royalties are for Democracy Now
which is a non-profit why don't you take
it yourself because I want to shore up
independent media in fact we're on a
more than seventy City book and media
tour called the exception to the rulers
tour and we are going from independent
radio station to IND
pennant radio station we start in Bai
big fundraiser for WBA I headed on the
55th anniversary of Pacifica KPFA to a
big celebration there and made our way
to Los Angeles and each of these hit Los
Angeles 2,000 people came out in
Minneapolis kay FAI the big community
radio station there we did a big
fundraiser 1500 people came out and I
think it is about a tremendous hunger
for independent voices people hungry for
searching for not the views of a fringe
minority as I was saying I mean I've
come to think about the corporate
networks in this way you have all of
these pundits actually it's a very small
group of them who know so little about
so much I'm beginning to think they sit
in a room and they just changed the logo
throughout the day CBS NBC ABC now
they're wringing their hands how did we
get it so wrong about weapons of mass
destruction why not invite someone into
the studios who got it right and who got
it right more than a year ago when it
mattered who is questioning the
credibility of the so called
intelligence and I'm not talking about
just people outside the system outside
the establishment but people in the
establishment people in the intelligence
agencies were saying no we are being
manipulated the intelligence is being
misrepresented I'm talking about
military families who are asking very
serious questions and now so many
servicemen and women have been lost let
me ask you this so you talk about CBS
NBC and ABC and lots of other if they
are so wrong about what they do why are
you all of them do what they do and you
do what you do I mean if you were right
wouldn't they look at you and say well
that that makes more sense than what
we're done it's not a matter of who's
right and who's wrong the but they're
making lots of money they are oh it's
working the question is what is working
a poll has just come out that shows
still that more than half the public
thinks that al Qaeda was linked to
Saddam Hussein that shows that more than
half the public thinks that weapons of
mass destruction were found I come from
New York the governor there is George
Pataki
he went to Iraq and he said he wanted to
take a little piece of the statue of
Saddam Hussein that was pulled down by
the US troops in April of 2003 the day
Baghdad fell and he want to take a
little piece of that statue and
incorporate it into the foundation of
the new World Trade Center if in fact
that happens it will be the first proven
link between Iraq and 900 all right
you're in charge all of a sudden you're
the president United States what would
you do differently well I'm a journalist
and if I were in charge of the network's
no I would just do if you're in charge
of the country in other words day after
day you criticize the people in power
and the war
what would you would you would you have
gone into Kosovo would you have gone
into Iraq under any circumstance would
you go on into a Rwanda to save the
massacre there yeah
that's not about the military killing
people Rwanda is a separate story and I
do think it's very important as you
raise that we're right around that we've
just passed the 10th anniversary of the
Rwandan genocide 10 years ago in some
10-day period almost a million Rwandan
swear massacred the US government knew
exactly what was happening this wasn't
the Bush administration at the time this
was the Clinton administration this was
President Clinton this was Madeline
Albright who is the US ambassador to the
United Nations in fact it was Richard
Clarke who was involved he was the
National Security Council at the time
they knew what was going on and they
chose not to act but it's I shouldn't
say not to act they did act they made
sure that in their public pronouncements
though privately they knew this they
would not use the word genocide because
that would trigger international law and
it would mean that they would have to be
involved in dealing with Rwanda what
happened there is one of the great
horrors of the 20th century and beyond
and it's unforgivable what the US
administration did yes as journalists
we're supposed to hold
all those in power accountable and as
for being present in the United States
or president of one of these networks
sometimes I think the networks are more
powerful than the President of the
United States it's about hearing the
voices of the people on the ground our
job as journalists is to give voice to
those people president's job whose by
the way just an employee of the American
public is if you're going to move into a
place like that is to hear what the
people are saying but the point was not
to invade to begin with you have a
excerpt from a speech by man named David
Rubenstein and first of all and you ran
it on your program where'd you get
speech I we got it
where'd he give it he gave it in Los
Angeles - and you can say there to get
the name correct but I think it was the
Los Angeles County Employees Retirement
Association that he was speaking before
and he had gone out to Los Angeles -
Employees Retirement socio Employees
Retirement Association - because they
wanted to divest from Carlyle Group the
private who is the first of all David
Rubin he is the head of the of the
Carlyle Group which is what what is very
significant is what this very powerful
private equity group private investment
firm is this is the private equity the
private investment firm it used to be
had by the former secretary of defense
under Reagan Frank Carlucci whose
ambassadors to the world included a
president bush senior he recently said
he left it James Baker continues to be
many high-level government officials who
leave and go right into the Carlyle
Group let me read this quote before we
run out of time and I want to ask you
about it this is David Rubenstein from
this speech April 23rd 2003 so it's not
that long ago year ago we put him on the
board and he spent three years came to
all meetings told a lot of jokes not
that many clean ones I kind of said to
him after three years you know I'm not
sure this is really for you maybe you
should do something else because I don't
think you're
that much value to the board you don't
know that much about the company he said
well I think I'm getting out of this
business anyway
and I don't really like it that much so
I'm probably going to resign from the
board and I said thanks
meaning David Rubenstein said thanks
didn't think I'd ever see him again
and you say then his name is George W
Bush did George W Bush serve on the Carl
board he served on subsidiary cold I
think it was cater heir of the Carlyle
Group and that's what David Rubenstein
was talking about as he talked to this
group trying to get them he was talking
about how he's not so close to the Bush
family and trying to keep this
retirement Association from divesting
but the important point here you think
it do you think David Rubenstein was
being truthful I don't know but there
are pretty interesting words to be
talking about George W Bush in this way
was this a private meeting and that they
supply you with the tape I got a copy of
the tape but well has this ever been
published before I mean is this this
book you've read on your show it was the
only place would that it or we first it
I don't know if anyone else took it from
there but what I will say is it's very
important to investigate The Carlyle
Group right this is the group that well
was holding their meeting in Washington
DC on September 11th George Bush Senior
was there the night before the bin Laden
representative was there the brother of
Osama bin Laden because they were main
funders of The Carlyle Group together
with the other former government
officials and so together they learned
about September 11th as they all said
together Bush had flown out that morning
but to investigate The Carlyle Group in
all its subsidiaries and the connection
to the Bush family the link between the
Bush family and the Saudi regime there
is a certainly a nexus there at the
Carlyle Group and most importantly to
understand that since September 11th
there has been so much suffering of
cross course on the part of families and
just communities what happened on
September 11th 3,000 people incinerated
moment but there's some who have
profited handsomely among them the
Carlyle
Group one of the major weapons
manufacturers now have profited
handsomely from what has taken place and
was certainly with the invasion of Iraq
all of these corporations that have made
a killing off the killing
Bill Clinton called you on vote day 2000
to do what I believe he was calling
radio stations in New York to get out
the vote for Hillary Rodham Clinton for
Al Gore that he was just calling in to
radio stations we didn't know he was
going to be making the call and what
happened well in fact it was a few
minutes before 9:00 we broadcast now at
8:00 live but then we used for cast at
9:00 few minutes before 9:00 I get a
call I have no idea first of all no one
calls us a few minutes before unless
it's an emergency a breaking news story
because we're getting on the air and we
get a call they say White House
communications I thought they said White
Horse communications which is a Tavern
in New York and they said White House
communications the president would like
to speak to you with the president have
a tavern what are they talking about
it's a president of what president
United States they said anyway I didn't
quite believe it but after we got off
the air the call did come in and we
raced into master control and did an
interview with President Clinton I mean
just Rica's we're out of time Bill
Clinton says now you just listen to me
you ask the questions and I'm going to
answer you have asked questions and a
hostile combative and even disrespectful
tone but I you have never been able to
combat the facts that I have given you
now you listen to this and he goes on
were you surprised and I said I just had
a few more questions no I was surprised
the next day when the White House called
and basically said I'd be banned from
the White House I said you called me and
they said you kept him on the line for a
half an hour I said he's the most
powerful man in the world he can get off
if he wants to we're out of time this is
the cover of the book our guest has been
Amy Goodman and the book is called the
exception to the rulers thank you very
much for joining us thank you Brian